standing eros is probably the most
underutilized character in both movie
adaptations of ads but in the novel
there's a lot more to help us understand
his character stick around to the end of
this video to find out why today's
lesson is sponsored by an infertility TV
hello welcome welcome you may be seated
they say it's the quiet ones you have to
watch out for and Stephen King's it's
definitely embraces that concept with
characters like Patrick Hawks Tedder and
Stan the man Aris my name is rabbi C's
world and today on horror history we're
going to Sunday school but we may not be
keeping it kosher Stan is one of the
seven losers club members who battle
against its the creature looming in the
sewers of Derry Maine like most of his
friends he grows up to be quite
successful but despite his best efforts
he and his wife are never able to have a
baby so for this episode I'm partnering
with infertility TV the YouTube channel
dedicated the helping you beats
infertility each week infertility TV
uploads a new video with science-based
tips from a board-certified fertility
expert to help you in your partner
maximize your chances for getting
pregnant so if you or someone you know
is having trouble like standed click the
link in the description to subscribe to
infertility TV today it's like having a
fertility specialist in your phone
Donald's URIs and andrea bartoli married
young in their early 20s and in 1946
they would give birth to their only son
and named him Stanley Stan had a Jewish
upbringing but unlike the 20:17 movie
adaptation of it where Stan is the son
of a rabbi the URIs is aren't
particularly Orthodox they don't keep
kosher and they don't attend synagogue
very often but that doesn't stop the
bullies in town from picking on him
because of his religion when Stan was 8
Henry washed his face with snow until it
bled and Stan was crying hysterically
each member of the losers Club was
picked on by Henry Bowers because they
had something about them that made them
difference but these differences are
also what made them gel as a group
however Stan was a bit of a different
case Bowers may have singled him out due
to his religious beliefs but I think
what makes him a part of the losers Club
is his introverted personality this even
comes across in the way that the book is
written throughout the novel each of the
other six losers club members have
moments where they're retelling their
own story but Stan keeps everything to
himself we only learn more about his
story later from the perspective of his
wife he tends to keep things to himself
which I see is him taking a huge load of
emotional stress and never really
releasing it by opening up to his
friends about it for this reason he
developed some of his own coping
mechanisms that are apparent throughout
his story
there are many coping mechanisms
recognized by psychologists and we can
use them to follow Stan's breakdown from
healthy to unhealthy ways of dealing
with his trauma stan has a close
relationship with his father who shared
his own passion of bird-watching with
his son together they would often go to
Memorial Park to watch Birds this was a
great spot because of the war memorial
statue in this park had once been
damaged in a storm and replaced with a
birdbath for budgetary reasons
Donald gave his son a gift to help him
identify some of the bird species it was
a book called MK Handy's guide to North
American birds Stan treasured this book
and often brought it with him whenever
he went out one day Stan went to
Memorial Park to go bird-watching
on this occasion his father did not
accompany him he heard a loud noise
coming
the standpipe the big water storage
structure a landmark of dairy the
standpipe used to be a popular location
there was a walkway near the top that
families would frequent to look out over
the town and a walkway over the water
known as the gallery in 1930s some kids
fell from the gallery into that water
during the night and had nothing to hold
on to and no way to climb out
they were found drowned at the next
morning and the Town Council locked up
the standpipe and did away with letting
families visit that's why Stan found it
strange that the noise he had heard at
the standpipes base looked to be a
padlocked door that had been blown off
he looked inside to see a narrow set of
stairs in the dark and he could hear
carnival music echoing off the metallic
walls he took one step inside the music
out louder and more horrifying as
squishy footsteps approached him Stan a
man of logic called out to the footsteps
asking who was there a voice replied to
him and said the dead ones he realized
that the door which seemed to be
destroyed was now locked shut behind him
and he was trapped
they told him you'll float to the
footsteps can tell him to approach and
stands only coping mechanism is to hold
out his bird book and scream out as many
names of bird species as he could think
of the door behind him opened with a
scream and he fell back into the outside
grass but before he ran he saw a
purplish black jeans small orange
pom-poms in a white gloved hand
beckoning him in the dark along with the
kids who drowned in the standpipe
so in this instance stan is faced with
what I would consider to be maybe the
scariest thing that any of the losers
Club members ever encountered and he
turns to his first coping mechanism
escaped by focusing on his passion
bird-watching he takes himself out of
the moment and he basically redirects
his fear of it's making him a less
attractive target and also possibly
hurting it in June of 1958 his friend
Richie Tozier brought him along to help
the losers Club build a dam in the
Barrens and they all immediately became
friends stan and been discovered they
had the same class together in second
grade but stan was so quiet back then he
never said anything they end up getting
in trouble for building the dam with a
cop named mister now since it caused
issues with the water systems in town
each one of the boys stepped forward to
admit some responsibility until Stan was
the only one left and then he too
claimed to be anonymous this is a small
detail but maybe an early clue towards
Stan's reluctance to be in any of the
club's conflicts
he's peer pressured again when they make
the promise at the end
that summer later that June when some of
the other kids go to see the werewolf
movie stan has to stay home and do
chores all weekend because he destroyed
a window while playing Flying Saucer
with the plates which I have to say
sounds 100% worth it so Stan is
basically grounded for a couple weeks
and he shows back up around the time
that Beverly is telling the boys her
story about her encounter with it's the
bloody bathroom sink in her apartment
it was Stan's idea for all of them to go
back and clean things up and after doing
so they bring the bloody rags to the
laundromat to clean them where Stan also
offers his 50 cents to run the machines
during this time Ben tells of some of
the other boys encounters with AIDS but
Stan is reluctant to talk about his he
would eventually tell the story about
what happened at the standpipe but it
tells the others he believed it was a
dream this is his next coping mechanism
deny and it's one that he uses more
often than any of the others because he
didn't want to believe that they were in
danger and by going into denial he
didn't have to accept it when Eddie
suggests that they go to the police and
Stan is the most realistic about their
situation right Stan said dead kids in
the standpipe blood that only kids can
see not grownups clowns walking on the
canal balloons that blow against the
wind mummys lepers under porches chief
Borton will laugh his bum off and then
he'll stick us in the loony bin this is
Stan trying to distance himself from the
group not because he doesn't love them
but because he's the most afraid of it's
out of any of them
and he doesn't know how to properly deal
with these emotions but the following
month he'd be forced to come to terms
with the situation when he experiences
something so terrifying that he hits an
absolute breaking balls
on July 3rd in 1958 Stan and the other
members of the losers Club came to the
aid of Mike Hanlon by fighting off Henry
Bowers and his thugs in the apocalyptic
Rock fight as Stan saw everyone
gathering rocks he had to press his lips
together in order to have the courage to
stay in fights Stan ended up helping in
the barrage of rocks that knocked Henry
to the floor by nailing him in the shin
when Henry had been driven away Stan
invited him to shoot off firecrackers
with them and Mike ended up joining the
club of becoming the seventh and final
member after this quarrel the losers
create their own Clubhouse in order to
hide out from Henry when necessary
Mike tells his new friends about his
encounter with one of the forms of it's
a giant bird that had attacked him at
the remains of the old ironworks and
based on the description of the bird
Stan thinks it's a species that's only
been known to exist in South America
causing him to go pale especially when
mike tells about how big it was
stan is also the one to suggest that now
that mike has shared his story with them
they'd all be able to see it which may
have been key in their eventual battle
with the bird form in the sewers of
Derry standing Beverly go into town to
get hinges needed to complete their
clubhouses door and after the
construction is complete on July 6 Mike
brought his father's photo album to the
Barrens to show his friends the album
had been used to document some
historical photographs from dairies
history and was filled with subtle
appearances by penny wise they land on
one photo of Derry that comes to light
and Pennywise dances and flips around
the page then he runs up to a lamppost
in the foreground and speaks directly to
the losers the plastic slot that the
photo is cased in bulges out towards
them as Pennywise cycles through his
many forms including the dead boys that
Stan had seen in the standpipe remember
Stan had been finding ways to suppress
his fear of it up until this point
telling himself that each episode was a
dream or hallucination and he tries to
do the same thing here he goes into a
manic episode snatches up the book and
slams it shut then hold it closed on the
ground while yelling the word know over
and over the others forced him to admit
that he saw the same thing that they all
saw another example of his subjection to
peer pressure but when he finally does
agree that what he saw was real he's
able to smile and crack a joke about
Bill's stutter because sharing his fear
with his friends is the healthy response
that Stan should have been using all
along humor is also one of the coping
mechanisms considered to be an adaptive
neck
basically a healthy response bill
however still senses some hysteria and
Stan which tells me that he still has
some demons locked away the losers
decide to conduct a smoke hole ceremony
which is an Indian ritual where they
would sit around a smoke hole and
breathe in fumes until they had a vision
that was supposed to help them someone
had to stay up top to pull out whoever
passed out and Ritchie thought that
Eddie or Stan would be quick volunteers
Eddie said nothing Stan stood pale and
thoughtful and silent however when the
smoky air started to get heavy stan was
the first one to climb out of the
clubhouse perhaps it foreshadowing of
him being unable to deal with the
pressure when it's comes back in 1985
where he is also the first one out
closer to the end of that month after
Eddie's arm is broken by Henry Bowers
and his friends Stan joins the others
and visiting Eddie in the hospital and
Stan signs his cast across Eddie's wrist
not sure if that's a sign of things to
come for Stan or just a coincidence
Stan was also there when the losers
investigated Beverly's claims of having
seen its kill one of the boys
Patrick Hawk said when they arrived they
discover a notes left by Pennywise in
blood that reads stop now before I kill
you all the words to the wise from your
friend penny Wong so I got a digital
copy of this book and looking at it on
screen makes it look very much like this
was written by a fourth grader and
mspaint but anyway this sends bill into
a frenzy of anger and crying and stan
has to grab him by the arm to prevent
him from hurting himself this is where
they all silently agreed to help bill
avenge his little brother on July 23rd
the losers go to Bill's house to make
silver slugs that Beverly would later
shoot out of the slingshot at penny wise
to fool bill's parents they act like
they're playing Monopoly and Stan who
would later become a rich accountant was
the winner two days later on July 25th
the seven of them turned up at twenty
nine niebolt Street to confront penny
waffles Stan brought with his North
American birds guide in case he needed
to protect himself like he did before
they come across a corridor where the
wallpaper animates in a horrifying way
and the room shrinks in on them causing
Stan to cover his eyes and scream bill
punches up through where the ceiling
appears to be to prove that the room is
not as it seems and proved to the losers
that if they don't believe in its
manipulations then it's can't hurt them
Stan however argues that someone like
him wouldn't have been able to do that
bill was only able to do it because he
was fighting for his brother but bill
reminds him that he already has he did
the same thing at the standpipe Richie
asked him if he's a man or
he's an ass - which Stan says I must be
a man so far as I know mice don't bear
pants Stan once again uses humor to
defuse the situation and doing so
actually physically deters it then has
the feeling that the house is literally
pulling away from them as they laugh
after the fight with Pennywise in the
bathroom where Beverly drives its back
down into the sewers with the slingshot
Stan cracks yet another joke but the
happy times only last so long with the
final confrontation of the summer
looming in the near future two weeks go
by before the day arrives the day that
seven children in Maine and join hands
to make a promise a promise that would
get two of them killed twenty-seven
years later it starts innocently enough
Stan is out in town getting popsicles
with Richie Tozier and Eddy casts
Braddock and the three boys are having a
discussion about how Stan doesn't keep
kosher they end up running into Bill
then Mike before crossing paths with a
panting Beverly Marsh and Ben Hanscom
they were being chased by the boys
apparently Henry Bowers had snapped and
was now doing its bidding it was time
for their big showdown with the show
clown and Ben led them to the pumping
station where the seven of them would
climb down into the sewers all while
being chased by Bowers and company
because they were being followed
Stan who was the most afraid of it out
of everybody was once again forced to
stay with a group and he was hitting new
levels of anxiety while travelling
through one of the pipes something
splashes nearby and Stan's screams and
bursts into tears
they light a match and discover it's the
dead body of Patrick Hawks deader which
it's had dragged into the sewers to
feast on as they navigated each one of
the kids realized the sewer smell was
being replaced by the smell of their own
fears and for Stan that was an awful
memory from his early childhood
it smelled like clay mixed with oil and
made him think of an eyeless mouth less
demon called The Golem the clay man that
renegade Jews were supposed to have
raised in the Middle Ages horror movie
fans may remember one of the very first
horror films ever made the 1920 German
Expressionism picture titled The Golem
stands simply could not deal with being
this uncomfortable terrified wet lost
and filthy the group is attacked by it
this time in the form of a giant eyeball
with tentacles then they reach an area
that somehow resembles a cathedral and
light seems to be coming out of the
walls this
is where the giant bird that might
concede makes a return and dives at them
Stan the bird spotter was literally the
first to spot it it swoops in and
scratches Eddie ripping his shirt and
doing so Mike took his buck knife and
cut the birds talons as it came in to
attack Eddie again and in retaliation
and the bird left a long cut on Mike's
arm he dropped the knife and it
disappeared into the dark the bird came
back for them and now Eddie and Mike
were defenseless this is where stan had
his bravest moments he steps forward in
front of his friends and screams out
proclaiming his belief in several
different bird species that he knows
from his book despite the fact that he's
never personally seen them but then he
calls out but I don't believe in you so
get the heck out of here with that the
bird disappeared into the dark allowing
them to continue on to the spider's lair
when Stan first saw the spider he
shrieked like a baby but when Bill
engaged in the metaphysical battle of
its Stan understood that the ritual of
tchard had begun after Bill had driven
it away he sensed a feeling of doubt on
Stan's face unsure that they had really
finished it off for good after making it
out of the sewers alive bill asked the
others to make a promise Stan finds a
discarded coke bottle and smashes it
open on a rock and uses the shards to
cut each of their palms so that they can
initiate a blood Oh Stan makes a joke
about cutting his wrists instead a
definite foreshadowing of his eventual
death
the seven make a pact that if it should
ever return they would come back to
defeat it once more in the years that
followed the losers would one by one
leave Derry Stan was a very good student
and secured a scholarship to New York
State University one night he went along
with a friend to attend a sorority party
at another school and it was there that
he was introduced to Patricia Blum and
the two quickly fell in love by spring
the two were engaged at the age of 22
Stan's parents criticized his marriage
despite the fact that they too had
married extremely young patty is working
to get a job as a teacher and stan
recommends that she applied for this job
in Atlanta she gets it and although the
pay is not good the Eurus is moved from
New York to Georgia in August of 1972
Stan and patty were married
hi I'm Stan starts by getting a job
driving a bakery truck for a hundred
dollars per week but in November he got
a job at a tax preparation company
called H&R Block where he would make
$150 this doesn't sound like much but
when the figure is adjusted for
inflation to 2019 it comes out at
$900 their combined income was over
17,000 a year or roughly over a hundred
thousand in 2019 in 1973 they decided to
say goodbye to the birth control pills
to try to start a family but no baby
came during the next two years then in
1975 Stanley quit his job to start his
own accounting firm in 1979 Stan and
Patty moved to a suburb called Traynor
where a company called corridor video no
not them that's corridor digital
corridor video actually dealt with
literal videotapes mirch link in
description they moved on to a piece of
land nearby and turned into a huge
client for Stan and eventually earned
him a full-time position at the company
making 30,000 a year but more
importantly putting Stan in contact with
some of the richest and most powerful
men in Atlanta who I can only imagine or
Ted Turner Hank Aaron Jeff Foxworthy and
the magician as their income continued
to grow they focused more of their
attention on trying to have kids and
went to a fertility specialist in
Atlanta who told them there were no
physical problems preventing them from
conceiving by 1983 Stan was making six
figures which were adjusted for
inflation is equal to over a quarter of
a million dollars a year in 2019 okay
that's enough math here in the horror
history classroom and the point is that
Stan was finally making the kind of
money that Bill teased him about during
that Monopoly game and other than their
unexplained infertility Stan had a very
happy and comfortable life that all
changed in an instant on the evening of
May 28th 1985
there were only two members of the
losers club who didn't block Derry and
the killing spree that occurred there
from fall 1957 through the end of summer
in 1958 from their memories the first
was Mike Hamill and that's only because
he never left town
the other was Stanley URIs perhaps Stan
took on so much emotional damage having
gone up against the dead boys in the
standpipe the image of the clown in the
photo album had giant bird in the sewers
and the inter-dimensional spider in the
sanctum that he was simply unable to let
his guard down in the 27 years that
followed two weeks before the call that
changed everything Stan had discovered
that his old childhood pal build n
burrow was a very successful author and
Stan's wife had begun reading one of his
books when Stan picks up the phone on
May 28th he's also able to remember his
old buddy Mike Hanlon but he almost
immediately goes quiet which I see is
the realization that there could only be
one reason that Mike was called it's had
a return over the course of this lesson
I've discussed a variety of Stan's
coping mechanisms there are positive
ones known as adaptive coping mechanisms
these include supports like when Stan's
friends are there for him and they talk
to him about the issue or humor like
when Stan makes a joke to defuse the
tension then there are maladaptive
coping mechanisms the negative ones like
escape when Stan takes his mind to
another place such as his birds are
numbing like when he tries to drown out
the horrors happening around him
but there's one maladaptive mechanism
that Stan's seemingly has not tried yet
self-harm at 7 p.m.
Stan decides to take a bath after some
time being locked behind the door Stan
was unresponsive so patty found the
spare keys and unlocked the door to find
she was already too late the word it was
written on the side of the bathtub in
Stan's blood Stan was intelligent but
often quiets and out of his group of
friends he had the most trouble learning
to deal with the terrors that they
encountered in a summer of 1958 at the
hands of penny wise for these reasons
the trauma he endured stuck with him in
his adult years in a way that none of
the others would relate to and
ultimately it ended up being his
downfall that concludes today's lesson
on Stan Harris this has been another
episode of
your homework is to let me know in the
comments who I should analyze next
episode and click the playlist on the
left to see infertility TVs analysis on
how Black Widow from the Avengers could
have gotten pregnant remember to
subscribe to seize these worlds for new
Horrors every week bring that death Bell
for notifications and I'll see you in
the next one assuming we both survive